hello welcome to this video playing
grandma see your shake wow I've got a
super bad score against him one out of
six it's not good so yeah this is was
clear that this is the line but I didn't
think it's so good so bad for me I
played him before I do you place those
tricky lines and lines that are
essentially not correct but post
problems this is this is probably one of
them I came so what is happening here c6
he's gone school 96 I guess 94 that's
Queen d5 okay if I castle it's not
working so what about a 6 a-6 f40 x fe
594 that looks dangerous e 6f for the
sugar for Bishop f4 85 85 hmm down
tricky it's tricky so c6 text takes
Knight e 4 25 check
don't like my position to be honest
that's weird
I have to shut the door I'm sorry about
the sounds him my washing machine is
making off what sounds them so i have to
go t 5 here before he comes with kundi
five I know he can take me if I was
checked while I have c6 and queen bee
six then
so you just took it so I'm a clear pawn
up but position is wide open
something like Bishop d3 castles queen
age five might be what he's thinking of
and of course he has gained considerable
time on the clock with his some offbeat
opening hymn
nobody's catching up on time now yeah
yeah I couldn't really make that work
check okay that was the idea interesting
so if i move the king queen chicks check
24 there is no big point there should be
six takes Queen d7 queen bee seven and
then I've upon down actually not a big
deal but still
hmm i don't want to play passively hear
this let's cam that porn queen d7 Queen
B 7 and just canceled
I'm pretty active so that probably is
enough why for the pond put the bishop
still back there and so on so what now
Queen D for is that just a pretty
useless check candidates okay 24 next
attacking a to NC 2 again here is a text
two pawns
any other drawing margin yes they're
pretty high anyway with opposite colored
bishops see going from some kind of a
check don't know b3 Queen a six so
that's no problem a wants to go bishop
if I am to go on the long diagonal as my
queen is currently a little bit
misplaced and the phone is a ticket c5
this should be 535 we can also take time
morning no it's got an initiative him
it's got an initiative here
and the 40 seconds are the biggest
problem
still nothing going on here 30 seconds
though check
I exchange Yates ok finally tricked me
with my time problem at resins yeah no
it's completely ok the position of
course but I screwed up oh yeah I can
just play this and win chat ok I have
the story against this guy it's just
yeah I don't know whatever I'm just not
doing well against him I can't matter
that the opening is pretty weird it's
clear that this is angling for the
sacrifice but I didn't think it said
that have been that big of a problem
maybe five whatever is very tricky now
probably i found the best reply i mean i
played what the engine also wants to do
this this there's no Queen d-force more
interesting in TM yeah here I'm just
okay check check check here ok the
compounds to play c6 and give the pawn
that way we're also also equal and chat
something like like this yeah I'm very
active yeah we'll get probably get both
pawns yeah well I was also completely
okie at the game p3 is just a blunder
that that janet is close to winning
already because of this awkward pinning
situation yeah that's awful and it's
also easy to play after that I mean here
nothing nothing happens okay miss Rooke
a 16 is a blunder you mr. gay one this
is what I should do and it's equal yeah
this is a bad way to end my winning
streak was such a [ __ ] game here
yeah yeah I've got no problems here
whatsoever just have to avoid to run
into that that one move on so Queenie
fire of course I can check winds and
then nothing happens okay can try to be
no time of course with this one minute
30 again 30 seconds with position is
nothing mmm there was an awful situation
in the opening opening that cost so much
time so note to self don't not play
Bishop c5 yeah of course I can just do
this this is this is leading to
absolutely nothing for wide but I
thought Bishop c5 this may be more
interesting here here why it has
absolutely nothing of course I can do
something like that it's a little bit
like the the Scotch the Scotch opening
with reversed colors which is equal no
matter whose it was movies okay thanks
for watching